[Music]
merry christmas everyone we hope you're
ready for a holiday extravaganza like
never before we have a huge show coming
up including back by popular demand our
knotty and nice list our feeding frenzy
with some amazing holiday treats a
festive christmas edition of the fastest
plus our annual secret santa gift
exchange it's our best one yet do not
miss it but first there's no better way
to get into the christmas spirit than by
cutting down your own christmas tree and
we sent jesse and harold out to chop one
down like the real men that they are
[Music]
we're at the hidden pond tree farm in
menden new jersey it's a five tradition
we do it every year we're here with
chris chris what's new this year we
added a little train ride for the kids
that they can take out through the
fields we added a snack bar and some
more bonfire pits for people to roast
marshmallows all right yeah we added
harold ford jr
you're here you're here a little
bipartisan christmas tree cut down now
harold's a little older than i am so is
he gonna be able to walk up all the way
to do this tree or can we hitch a ride
somewhere we'll take the train out oh
the train yeah infrastructure week
[Music]
this looks like a gut-felled tree
it's not that funny either these
environmentalist wackos probably don't
like the tree farm idea real trees are
sustainable an artificial tree ends up
in a landfill for a thousand years and
where do the artificial trees come from
they all come from the same place china
we have no supply chain issues our trees
grow here and they're all grown by real
farmers mayor pete no supply chain
issues right here you watch the saw
let's smell them first right
i feel like joe biden
[Music]
trees are just like people it's all
about genetics some are tall and skinny
some are short and fast harold it's not
the size of the tree that matters let me
write that down how many acres this farm
is 25 acres and how much fish i have 18
000 trees in the ground right now you
have to make sure that you check the
water in the stand every single day
johnny
sometimes you get a tree it looks really
nice in the front and in the back it's
trash that's a nice big one should i do
the honors
timber well done all right well done
well done
good job jesse thank you very much
here we go
[Music]
harold's never roasted a marshmallow
before we got to show them how it's done
this guy's a heck of a tree cutter he
did a great job you really did i really
did i'm a little sore yeah is there a
masseuse here
[Music]
so we'll have two hot ciders one with
bourbon one without thank you thank you
cheers merry christmas cheers this is
your first marshmallow roast it is with
you with me okay are you gonna double up
i'm gonna double up you're gonna double
up all right i'll double up uh uh
harold yeah look at that look at that oh
you got the hotter look at that
let's go back to the office we got to
erect this tray
we had to do what we
[Music]
the best story about all this american
american-made and it's contributing to
the good side of climate change
tell me we got a break
down the hall here we go erected
merry christmas everybody
five staff
it's time to decorate
johnny where are the bells
[Music]
jesse it was very good harold did you
enjoy yourself i did i did jesse didn't
get me with that sauce yeah yeah i was
just worried about roasted a marshmallow
too it is first that's good right
personally he burnt his to a crisp he
had to take two well that's a whole idea
isn't it no you got to make a golden
brown judge yeah there's a whole
strategy to that but then it did not
dissuade me i came right back at it you
did yes your second roast was much
better have you bought a bag for
yourself since
i have not uh greg has already told me i
went to the wrong camps over the summer
i can't believe you've never roasted a
marshmallow what are you doing as a
child by the way if you watch that with
the sound off it's like a new york
married couple
two
two
upper west side men happily married
picking out their tree for their
two-room condos not that there's
anything wrong no no no no
hot chocolate a little french bulldog
sleeps under the tree
the best uh the best part of the whole
thing though is that the thing that
wraps the tree i mean what an invention
that is
imagine why can't they do that for
everything you just put something like
wrapping presents you know what they
need it for
umbrellas yeah umbrellas right when you
go in
when you're trying to do it yourself
it's a nightmare how about the grocery
store yeah just throw all your crap and
it just goes like this
how about how about when people pass
away instead of a coffin you just fish
them right in there
and then they shoot them into the ground
they had timing why
yeah yeah people just stop dying around
christmas
they worry about it you just killed the
tree for christmas
but you know what the tree doesn't care
oh
you think the tree doesn't have feelings
it's a conscious being yeah
yeah but you know what but the tree
finds love in your house that's right or
on the 21st floor yes
yes
i think it has to go through harassment
training the tree don't we all yes over
and over again all right we're not done
with the holiday fun there's an amazing
neighborhood right here in brooklyn
where people take christmas to the very
next level so judging and i went to
check it out
well there's no better way to get in the
christmas spirit than to come to a
neighborhood like dyker heights in
brooklyn the entire neighborhood goes
all out and over the top with lights and
music and amazing community spirit i've
never seen so many lights in my life and
that's why so many people come here to
kind of share the holiday cheer let's
check it out
a hundred thousand people come through
here a hundred thousand people i believe
that i have to do it it gets you in the
spirit
i am in the spirit
i love that it's beautiful
do you think they put these things in
their basement all year i think maybe
they have a storage unit perhaps lucy
spot over here you started this
amazing tradition in diker heights in
1986 what was the inspiration
well i moved here in 1986
and it was a very dead area
very quiet and i'm not one for quietness
i started very little
and then it just grew and grew and grew
and everybody caught on you have any
idea what your electric bill is it's
nothing
nothing nothing i want to move to diker
ice
dana i love this house i love the
architecture it looks it almost looks
like a palace like here you are you
drive in from brooklyn and then you go
up to the palace in paris
the paris of brooklyn i love it too i
think it's gorgeous it is gorgeous
should we go knock on the door well what
do you think would happen if you knock
on the door and then there's judge
jeannie do you think they don't want us
there
i think that no trespassing means no
trespassing judge it says also says no
junk mail no flyers no take away menus
and no free newspapers thank you that
doesn't leave me out
i wouldn't i would love can we find out
who lives here on call yes
castle i can do my fox nation castles
here
wait you should do that i'm gonna do
that okay i will well i like it that we
can add more assignments to your list
yeah why not i'm not busy are you no
this house is beautiful too what a
neighborhood it's absolutely gorgeous
this neighborhood is amazing yeah it
really is stunning let's go check out
this greenhouse well there's a lot of
green
[Music]
you'd do the decorating how many lights
you put on a house like this so this
house has 32 000. 32 000. 32 lights that
sense oh thirty two thousand cents so
judge dyker heights is amazing it is but
one thing that's truly amazing is that
when you and i are together neither of
us have to wear high heels
i love that we can wear our flats
yes yes see i got flats on how about you
yeah i went for the low wedge yeah
listen i love this house and i'll tell
you why
i don't know this house i don't know who
lives here but they took an ordinary
tree and they kind of made it look like
a mushroom and they just took little
lights like that makes me want to go to
kohl's or home depot or lowe's and get
white lights and try it i'd probably
kill myself falling off the land i like
that they have the theme of the
all-white lights i think yeah and the
toy soldiers of course yeah you can't
get in the front door you know no i
guess you can
another big guard
[Music]
the community spirit in this
neighborhood must be something pretty
amazing for everybody to come out and do
this every year we just grow more and
more adding more lights more decorations
just become part of you know the fun
that takes place in dike ice and
christmas lights
well judge jeanine and i encouraged
everyone to go i had no idea uh that
this existed and right there in new york
and brooklyn and you loved it yeah i
loved it you know there were so many
people there it was stunning i mean it
really is a place that you go to see the
christmas lights and i'm still want to
know what their bills are because i got
my gone ahead bill my friend's ready to
hang myself from the tree that they
didn't light yet no there you go
bringing up death again how much did
your hat cost
my hat is so old the hair person here
took the took the knit top out of it and
just plopped it on my head you should
have worn that hat today on the set no
no i'm christmassy it's not good as are
you have you noticed something missing
from christmas though that nobody talks
about the little mistletoe that has been
me tooed out of existence we don't even
talk about it anymore there's no
mistletoe to be found and it's made in
one place and i guess it's in oregon
yeah why would that be me too everybody
likes to kiss somebody whoever you like
to kiss kiss him yeah but you know what
at the office party yes
no i'm thinking in my kitchen
who's in your kitchen yeah it's hot up
there in the kitchen the plumber must be
thrilled
oh
[Laughter]
just keep talking hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else